unexpected cameos and a major character
transformation The Savage She-Hulk was
finally brought to life on screen in the
season finale of She-Hulk attorney at
law Tatiana maslani's Jennifer Walters
also known as She-Hulk faced several
surprises first off a creepy one-time
dates Todd ended up being the whole King
and The Mastermind behind Intelligentsia
and he was able to cunningly get his
hands on a sample of Walter's blood we
also discovered that Emile Blonsky
played by Tim Roth is still turning into
Abomination telling Walters ah yeah I do
speaking engagements nothing bad
strictly for profit and to top it all
off after being M.I.A for most of the
Season Mark ruffalo's Bruce Banner
literally dropped in to save the day but
is this a She-Hulk show Walter steps in
and decides that this is not the finale
she wants after realizing the writers
are not the ones in control she fights
her way to the knowledge enhanced visual
interconnectivity Nexus to plead her
case for the ending her character
deserves but before we get to the the
chaos of she-hulk's last episode we're
treated to an entirely new retro opening
credit scene complete with voice over
narration and late 70s early 80s style
Graphics as reminiscence of the original
The Incredible Hulk series opener but
unlike the cheerful playful and
beautiful She-Hulk we're used to seeing
we get a much bigger angrier and more
aggressive She-Hulk who looks an awful
lot like she could be Lou ferrigno's
twin don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when I'm angry
at the opening finishes the title card
reads the Savage She-Hulk for those who
don't know the Savage She-Hulk moniker
has a much longer and deeper history in
the Marvel Comics World beginning with
the very first She-Hulk issue and coming
back to the Forefront in The Avengers
comic series that started in 2018.
She-Hulk wasn't always a level-headed
intelligent Hulk that Tatiana maslani
portrays her to be in the mcu's She-Hulk
attorney at law when Stan Lee and John
busemma first introduced She-Hulk in
1980 it was as the Savage She-Hulk in
fact Jen Walter's origin story was
pretty different from the version
introduced in the Disney plus Series in
the comics Walter was shot by the
henchman of a mobster she had a case
against and Bruce Banner who had just
come back into his cousin's life
performed an emergency blood transfusion
to save her while recovering in the
hospital Walter star stonosis that she
feels different but assumes it's the
results of the medications the doctors
and nurses gave her but when the gunman
come to the hospital again to try and
silence her Jen's rage transforms her
into what became known as The Savage
She-Hulk this title lasted for 25 issues
with the first mention coming from a
nurse who had knowingly tells Walters
that female Savage was just horrible
fans of both Marvel Comics and the MCU
know that banners Hulk has always been
different the Hulk genuinely has a
separate personality from banner and is
consumed with causing destruction and
shares no consciousness with him
although ruffalo's Professor Hulk
appears to reconcile both despite the
comic's title Savage She-Hulk Walters
and her Hulk were always the same person
sharing the same Consciousness even so
Walter still thinks of herself as more
of a beast now referring to herself as
the Savage She-Hulk in Savage She-Hulk
issue 2. drawing Jason Aaron's run
writing The Avengers comics in 2018 he
tried to make She-Hulk more like the
Hulk but it didn't go over so well with
fans in a particularly unfavorable
Reddit Thread about the comics one user
wrote Aaron derailed She-Hulk and keeps
doubling and tripling down on it
unsurprisingly the care character
eventually reverted to the form fans
seem to prefer in Avengers issue 50.
[Music]